哈喽各位同学大家晚安
正式课程等一下会开始
9点准会开始我在讲什么
那我投影片都还没开
我刚好来回答一下同学的问题
同学有一个这个问题是
他在问台子期的同学
这个60k算是好的破底翻的点吗
你说位置有点尴尬
我们来看一下
60k的台值期
你讲的应该是在这边
对不对
那你问说
我看一下
位置有没有点尴尬
来
如果你用这个角度看60k
对吧
这个边界
这里来碰
跌进去了以后
由上往下
又再度来碰
而且这边注意
在我们的晚上
每股时间有停顿
其实如果你在这附近
有下单我觉得不会有太多的问题
只不过坦白讲纯60k
顶多你是下你先拉回来
就是该下去下不去拉回来的瞬间你买在这
然后当做整个是大破翻的这种角度吃手这个地方
大概就只有这种折中的方式吃
这样好不好
然后所以这个是你说4月2号就在这里吧
然后同学说今天4月7号早上台子期9点是算是可以互换位回彩的地方吗
你说这里吗
这个对不对
来我跟同学们这样讲好了
第一我们你要讲的应该是回到这一根对不对
你讲的应该是像这样子这一瞬间的看盘对吧
从我们交易的角度来看
我其实没有很喜欢
把单子下单在
按下去没多久
存60哦
就容易撞这个墙壁的地方
除非你在这个里面
这个框框里面
进到当时的五分K
去做当时的事情
这样子
不然如果存60这张单子
很难按
但是这个长下影线
它其实预告着你
后面很容易往上涨
这倒是真的
因为这个下影线跌破跌进这个边界理论上应该要继续跌下去但是他却没有这样然后我有看到底下这位
8382同学
那
你说
在外面不打单不乱
不过遇到昨天打回原型
我跟你说
你不孤单
大家都一样
我也是
你不要觉得我很厉害
没有
我跟大家都一样
我每天都在面对自己的心理状态的起伏
到现在都一样
我没有比较厉害
好不好
那你说
所以你一开始的乱掉这段过程
你反而要很开心的
注意哦
很开心的跟老天爷说
谢谢老天爷
感谢你给我这个机会
把我的缺点在这个地方
全部摊开来在市场上
让我知道感谢老天爷
感谢你
好
确定有哪些
这么多过度交易
凹单
然后报复性交易
好多
没关系
感谢老天爷
我一次调一个
我慢慢调
结果下个礼拜又报一个
再感谢他一次
这个时候
你就要注意
他在教你什么
如果你是同一件事情继续犯
刚刚底下好像我看到那个
那个MRSS222同学
就是你有直接讲
就是你的错如果一直没有改
然后又一直重复犯
那其实你进市场交易是没有意义的
因为你之前就是这样爆掉的
那我的建议是
你可以把自己很丑陋的那一面
例如说你打了一堆
假设打了圣诞树
或是凹大单
买进然后凹到这边停损
你把这个很丑陋的这一张图
你的内心最不敢面对的这一张图
印出来
贴在哪里
旁边的墙壁上
我跟你说真的有效
你把圣诞书列出来
一贴上去
然后凹单的亏损
大亏损
账号贴上去
你会有一些警惕的作用
你要下单以前就抬头看一下那一张
自己很烂的
有朋友来你家来介绍一下
这是我自己乱做的单子
不过贴出来老婆就会知道所以你也不要欺骗老婆好不好我反而觉得我不会骂你因为其实你自己知道
你自己知道问题在哪里
只是你想要我来帮你做double check
说老鱼敲我一下,来老鱼念我一下,这样比较好
没有啦,你自己知道我反而不会念
我会念的是那些
自己都不知道自己在干嘛的
然后满脑子想要征服市场的那种
那个我就会狠狠的念下去
这样好不好
有同学说有效我做过
我的新数还没出
剩最后大概一两个章节的一些部分
这样子
应该最后一个章节的一两个段落
这样
有同学说每次都
都把爆掉的方式写下来
是啊 有同学说打模拟账号会
打模拟单会过
会赚钱 但是EX账号就会爆
那我跟你说
如果你是真仓账号会爆炸
通关后的账号跟真仓账号的概念是一样的
然后模拟单会都过得了
就代表你在真实账号里面太畏首畏尾
你太害怕失去
所以反而你施展不开来
各位有没有这种感觉
你在模拟舱
这边打个几口
那边打个几口
神勇的跟什么一样
这边赚钱那边赚钱
然后在增舱就是各种畏畏缩缩
对不对
一下子怕这个怕那个
我没有要你一开始就直接放大部位
这也的确不对
但是当你开始有一些累积以后
你有正的获利的时候
你可以适当的扩大一些你的部位
赚一些钱拿一些子弹拿出来用
多加几口
那打输了回家睡觉
至少你没有倒赔
对吧
那不小心你会有某一天
你就因为你的加码而打赢的
那那天你的获利会突然间从
本来是这样子的
会突然间
噗噗
涨出来
那我这边叮咽一下
特别大的获利的隔天
拜托拜托拜托
请缩小不韦
我自己的经验都是
大获利的那天
我很爽 我好厉害
打得很厉害 对不对我的屁股就会翘起来所以隔天我就会放松了本来选途很严谨的心
在隔天全部都不见
就觉得自己很厉害
打这个也算
打那个也算
多也做
空也做
通常这一天都是大赔的一天
是吧
有人问说特斯拉是跳楼大拍卖吗
是哦
特斯拉是跳楼大
小娜
小那
好了
现在八点
错过这个点
可能我也不太想下
因为待会就九点半了
等开盘后
开盘后
动作快我也不想下
好不好
来特斯拉四跳楼大拍卖
而且
特斯拉现在这个位置是
盘前我要看
应该看我的单
是我自己的
长线单的
长期的这个均价的附近这里
所以我其实在等
等这附近震荡看怎么样
最近前面的周线都是上影线
所以我其实还在等
我在等某一周停住以后出现
出现长这样子的
这可以画
反正出现长这样子的下影线
我在等
这个出现
我又可以开始继续加部位
加部位这样子
好不好
好
来
那
那我觉得我最近下单
我觉得可能是因为一方面川普战争的这些关系
我的下单都变得缓缓慢慢
没有什么感觉想要下长线单
我觉得可能也跟我比较专心在写书
可能也有关系吧这样
那你记不
我不知道大家记不记得
特斯拉当初创下480490那边
那个高点的时候
全市场都在叫你买特斯拉
美国的各个政治人物也好
然后谁说特斯拉买买买
然后买完就下来了
对吧
所以你不要看新闻
不要听那些网路上的各种网红
在讲什么东西的
你唯一要评估的就只是
他都已经从当时从200多走到500多
走到400多块500
你真的还要继续拼吗
对
我这个那个时候那一周我还记得
我有讲过
来
我同学说刚刚也吃了
早上做完了
可以吧
刚刚吃两口
可以啦
刚刚那边我觉得不错
大陆的可以买电子版吗
我不确定
这个要问出版社
我可以跟他们讲一句
有国外的网友会想要买
然后看他们怎么做
我那个决定权可能不在我身上
我们来看一些同学问的股票
你这个股票
我看一下
周K可以观察吗
周K
周K不错
其实是不错的
这个周K这样子
那我看一下日K
有耶
这个140块的边界
这边开始在
我在涂鸦上面
我约略看得出标准图的样子
只不过这边稍微低了一点点
这一次有一点点算是隐忧的感觉
所以你心里要知道这边底下
可能还是会有几个
在这边鬼混的机会
还蛮高的
如果它有哪一天出现像这样子的K棒
这样子的K棒
这样子把这个平到148
又走回到
例如说这个附近
这个空空附近
如果是这样
那个图形的
那个均衡度
就会出来了
好不好
这种感觉
OK
小娜开盆了
对
我刚刚同学吃这边
不错啊
吃这边的同学脑袋中
都已经隐约
有一个破底翻的样子
对不对
很好啊
然后还有
我刚刚上面好像有看到我同学要问什么股票
是不是
问袁泰的同学你一直问
你好像还问另外一只什么
我们看一下2478
今天破了又收回来可以躲旁边吗
今天代表你讲的是日线
这个破了又收回来
它算蛮不错
有意义哦
因为它跌破的边界还蛮多的
你看这是一个从2月3月这边
累积到现在4月了
所以这两个点
这个跌破理论上要变成是像这样子
像这样子的大K棒
出现在这个地方要变成这样
这个东西其实还不错
你要怎么切入
我跟你说进到小10K
因为小10K它才刚开始而已我的这个软体后面这边会跑出很奇怪的东西不要理他进到到小时K我跟你说你不用急它才刚开始所以你反而可以等小时K
比较均衡一点点
的出现在这个地方
所以大概会是
会是可能明天后天
今天礼拜二嘛
所以你可能可以等个明天
礼拜三礼拜四
再来观察这个行情
有没有留在
有没有往上走的一些力道
然后回来
并且留在5857点多这个附近以上
如果有
而且它产生在这边
在这边
这样子
那这就不错
这样好不好
然后同学要看黄金是不是
好黄金
我们看黄金
黄金
黄金4700
怎么看
做空死活下不去
来
各位请看一下黄金的样子
现在的黄金
它是不是卡在这个边界
那我就问你了
这个边界目前是由上往下测
对不对
但是这边的多单也没有很好做
这边的多单跟空单两边都
哇
两边都有道理
所以没有到很好做
所以我们进到更短刻度看一下
哇
更短刻度
那位做空的同学
第一个我不知道你空在哪
如果你是空在像这种上边界
关键边界尖尖的隔壁这样子
那这是很棒的空单
但如果你是空在中间
不上不下的这些地方
或是甚至空在最下面
哇这就很硬了
这也是为什么我很不喜欢
做突破单的原因
因为你突破追
但是你追出去你会追在这种地方
一不小心就回来
然后追另外一边多单突破追
哇又回来
所以我没有到很喜欢做这种
所以我不觉得现在这个空是好空点
然后另外我要提供个看法
各位你看一下黄金
前面都已经从5400跌到4400
跌了1000点的黄金
很强这样子
整个三月份还没走完可以跌1000点的黄金
现在的涂鸦的惯性
前面的惯性是往这边走请告诉我现在涂鸦的惯性是往哪里走往上往下就算是现在我看到的都还是这个涂鸦是在往上的
所以我不觉得在这边
做空是
是很好的那个点
那今天的课程时间
我觉得差不多了
我们九点就开始
先来上课一下
那一千点
黄金一口
获利多少
你可以算一下
黄金它是有那个小数点的
对不对
你可以去算一下
看你是做正常的大黄金
还是微金
不过那个你不可能做在
做在我们这种
这种当冲的这种考试平台上
你要做就要做在自己的真实部位
上面去做黄金这样
好不好
来
那我们今天要来聊
尖尖的
因为
因为我们在教学的过程中
其实有很多同学
他可能尖尖的学了一下子
一知半解
结果跑出去自己下单的时候
他看到每一个地方的尖尖的
都好想下单
那我们就要跟大家讲了
尖尖的只是所有交易机会判断的
其中一种模式
他有各种的前提
所以你不能说
把前提都忽略掉
然后只看到最后一步
他是有照顺序的
好不好
来那我们就来看一下
那先从同学的一些留言开始
那这是同学留言在我的影片里面底下的
这位chain reaction
连锁效应
边界什么时候应该在上下引线
什么时候应该穿越实体K棒
我只知道边界只能画个大概
的确是画个大概
发生压力化太上面
好
来
我教你化边界
我现在用刚刚的行情
我就用眼前的这个黄金
我教大家怎么化边界
例如说眼前这一段
我把行情回到这里
你有沒有看到
这个边界有很多
开
K棒的那个
关键的那四个价位
开高低收
要么是高点
要么是低点
要么是收
要么是开
反正就这四个价位
这个边界很多人碰
对不对
好
这里
放大一点在52405230多这附近这里有没有好多边界都约略停在这上面但是你看然后这里这里有一个人注意看
有12
这个也算34
有1234个人停在这边
包含这个人5
然后只有一个人
我用不同颜色圈最上面这个
只有他一个孤零零的在上面
那就代表他是那个不小心买在最高点的阿呆
或是空在最高点很厉害的人
不过那个那种空都是到最后都会是致命的空
对吧
所以我要讲的是
很多人使用的边界
毛边长在外面
长在外面
可以
那我就会把这个东西用下来
但如果这个毛边
这个边界跑到这里来
这个上线也到这里
这个也到这里
上面是不是有1 2 3
搭配这边又有4 5
我这么多人用
包含这个人由上往下踩6
那如果是这样子
底下这几个边界我就不理它了
我就会把刚刚我画的那个东西
假设它上影先都到这里
我就会拿它当做我的边界
然后我要等什么
等边界被撞上去
就是这个东西到时候要长在这里
因为这里太多人碰碰碰
所以我需要它破
我们不是在打麻将
我不会打麻将
就是要等它破
尖尖的隔壁
用现在小纳画边界
我们来看一下
小纳
现在小纳的
我们来到5K
5K的边界
一秒钟两秒钟讲完了
所有这边做的交易全部是在中间
那老于为什么你没有画这个
为什么你没有画边界画在这里
很简单啊
注意看哦
我这边对过来
是不是在这个涂鸦中间
我看一下我画你粗的画笔
涂鸦给大家看
我没有很精细的涂鸦
但是其实不需要
我就大致上这样涂鸦
高点低点
请用我的涂鸦
描绘出比较没有被碰到的边界
是不是
大概在这个地方跟这个地方约略就好了
不用很精准
我也随便画的
是吧
这样听得懂吗
所以我不会画在这里
但如果注意看
如果如果如果如果
这个K棒
这根尖尖的隔壁
它跑在这
上面的边界下面的边界
然后这根这根长在这个地方
它的隔壁就很重要了
因为如果这个边界要继续有效
它的隔壁就要往下走
对市场就是要这样走
你有没有可能会错
有
有可能会错啊
所以你就是读读看嘛
如果读对了这一段读错了那样子的损失
就是用大跟小来换嘛
对不对
有同学说
这几年下来个图形千百
对
重点不在于
在于这个足迹背后告诉你的是什么
是
例如说同学这句话我觉得很棒
虽然这也是我们一直都在讲的东西
例如有力量
很大量的往上撞
又被大量的瞬间的这样卖下来
对吧
但是我要问的是问
这个
长上影线的单子
它发生的地方来
我在这个地方标一条线
我们标一条
好
请看一下我画了这条线
我们到60k的格局
这是不是60k的下缘
大边界下缘
对不对
那刚刚的是
短刻度出现这样子的上影线
但是它出现的位置是在大边界的哪里
靠下缘的地方
这个其实等一下就都会讲到
所以呢
刚刚那样子的
就是属于一个不好的
我们喜欢如果要对做空有利的
是喜欢它的边界
行情来到这个地方
上去说回来
我要它出现这种实体K棒在这里
然后有个引线长在
注意长在边界的哪里
外侧
没有打破的外侧
那个我不喜欢
我喜欢的是打破
不管是上还是下
看你要做多或做空
这样好不好
这个图今天台子期下午4点有出现真的吗我们来看一下胎子期下午4点所以你讲的下午4点应该是
5分K
上面对不对 上面对不对
4点4点4点
这个吗 来好问题
老鱼老鱼
这个边界我在这里做空 老鱼说可以做空
等一下哦
既然你想要做空
你就在这边画一条线
然后你到大一个格度看
这个大格度可以耶
那我问你哦
当下这根K棒
这根K棒是原地停顿的K棒吗
各位什么叫原地停顿
这个好像上礼拜
还是上上礼拜什么时候我讲过
注意看哦
原地停顿的K棒
它有几个重点是
在这一根K棒
假设这是5分K
就这5分钟
K棒一开始要在这边
起跑点要在这附近
中间乱走
走上去走下去我不管
终点又要回来
哦
这个东西的融合就会变成是一个
这样子的上引线的K棒
然后实体K棒在这个地方
大概长这样子的K棒
请问这一根K棒虽然它缩回来
但是它五分钟前在这边起跑点
五分钟后的终点
他从332多少走到33359
对吧
那他有没有走一段路
有代表多单是有利的
所以这个单子这里就不适合做空
那什么时候适合假设
假设
这里来
我还宁愿你在这个地方
这个地方的做空
这个的做空会比刚刚这个做空来的稳定多了
但是你说后面老鱼还是被尬上去
那是另外一回事
我们讲的是几率的概念
这样好不好
好来那我再继续
我后面还有要聊的东西
同学说
如果停损到了以后才往预期的方向走
如何决定再次进场
来我跟你说
再次进场的时间点
应该这样讲
你把再次两个字拿掉
你根本不用再想这个是刚刚那一单的再次你只需要把头脑清空重新的用一个新的角度来看市场问自己现在符不符合我的交易计划
有没有照顺序符合我的大边界
POR所有的SOP都要有
就这样
所以三秒钟前你可能被停顺
但是你的脑袋就要立刻清空
前一单跟后一单
三秒钟后就没有感觉
没有关系
你必须要做到这样
因为如果你用那个再次进场
这个时候你会有一个盲点是
我们很容易会专注在
我刚刚亏多少钱
我那单可恶被打掉
那个报复的心态就很容易出来
这样好不好
然后再来
那你说稍微放上面一点
放下面一点点
我刚刚已经讲解过那个话的范围了
误差多少范围内才合理
我跟你说
我没有办法讲一个精准的东西
我就用眼前的台子棋来讲好了
我用当下的台子棋
这是最新的台子棋
现在的样子
来
误差是什么
在我的脑袋里面
这一个区域
包含这个上影线
在我的脑袋里
都是一块厚厚的木板
像我们在那个做装潢一样
一个比较厚的木板
在这个地方
凡是来到这边
各种上不去
边界在这里
所以我不会去
去很细的抓说
例如说这样子抓说
边界是这里
或是仔细看这个上影线
这里
还是这里
管它哪里
反正就这一整区
同样的道理
来这边有下影线
对不对
来你回来看
前几次来到这边都出现下影线
包含这里又有这个
所以我就知道边界下影线
所以来到33120 33160这一区
区域容易有人买
那跌下来了
居然真的出现在这个区域附近
你懂意思吗
好不好
我们看的概念就是市场在做什么事
就是刚刚同学讲的
这个背后告诉我们来到这个区域都有人买
那我这边讲个算是其他的观念一下对于越大的资金来说他不可能锁定说他就一定要在某一个很精准的价格吃
不可能
他资金太大了
所以对他来讲
他是在某个区域里面
慢慢的可能不是用一天
也不是什么一个礼拜
可能是好几个礼拜
他慢慢的去堆叠出他要的部位
他是用区域的概念
那资金越少的人
越没有资格跟人家玩这种区域的游戏
因为你承受不起
一次那个区域里面吃单打掉了后的停损
不行
人家大机构大法人们
他们是OK的
对不对
资金不大理论上必须要买得精准
但是你不能把要求精准这件事放在市场上
你只能大概八成像就差不多
就要下单了
因为没有百分之百的那个点不可能
对吧
所以八成可以的可以的按就这样子
那风险就是乖乖的守那个边界的风险
这样
我等一下会再继续讲
所以误差多少范围
跟你用哪一个刻度有关
来什么刻度
例如说
例如我用
来 刚刚5分K的小娜好了
例如我用5分K的小娜
假设你是吃在这边的人
你的防守就是这里
就是这段
这个距离我将目测大概20点吧
这样好不好 我目测
那如果你是吃在这边
对不起 你还是要守这里
为什么要守这么远
谁叫你要吃在靠近压力
又是尖尖的下引线的地方
这边就是我讲的
它有出现尖尖的 有
但是它尖尖的其实
没有什么意义你知道吗
因为它尖错地方
我只知道后面要上去
但是不好下单
但如果这个尖尖的发生的位置在
这里
如果它发生在这里我也不会下了
因为我的涂鸦会告诉我
变成是这样子
那我要重新的等待了
我不会把这边拿来当这个
我要做的
所以这个边界它理论上不应该再破
借我讲一下我刚刚是不是讲格局
对不对
5分K你就是守这里
来
15K
15K没有太多好下单的机会
30K
我们讲小10k好了
小10k假设你吃在这边
你吃在我举个例子
比较极端一点
然后底下这里
这就是你要吃的
你吃但你要防守的60k的边界
而且以60k来讲
其实你必须要把这一段
也包进去
因为这边是这里的最低点
所以我不觉得这边的60k很好吃
不同交易科度
它的包的那个范围
本来就不一样
越大的K棒
K棒本身的那个涵盖的价格刻度就越大
如果你要做日线单
欢迎啊
但一个日线的下影线就200点
200点算少
对吧
刚刚Peter说1K
1K
1K有
对
这个下影线就是我讲的
这是一个我很不喜欢
按下去就撞墙的尖尖的下影线
它尖错地方了
所以同样的尖尖的
我喜欢的是那种
叠下来
有没有
下面它又涨回边界的这种
这样这个感觉懂吗
再来
所以你说误差
跟你使用的刻度有关
好不好
那这是另外一个网友
他说如果买了以后遇到盘证怎么办
好问题
你买以前你不知道会遇到盘证
是吧
所以你买定以前
例如说我预计行情在这里买
我在这里买
然后买了以后
行情就在这里
不上不下整理怎么办
有一些网路上的说法会说
他会用时间停损
买进去其实就要喷
理论上我觉得这是对的
买进去就要喷
对吧
但是你有没有可能遇到
多整理一下
然后可能下午3点4点到了
哇直接喷出去的
也会遇到啊
所以我觉得最好的方式是什么
是你买进去了以后
在当时你做好你的风险计划
跟获利的获利计划
所以你的风险在这边
获利在这边
好
所以要嘛
他就打到你的风险
要嘛就有机会走到这边
然后你把风险拿掉
变成这边不赔
所以这个时候
你就是获利跟风险
那风险被拿掉了
就是获利跟没有获利
顶多就这样子所以这个时候你只剩下赚钱跟不会赔钱就这样那中间有没有可能他鬼混了老半天整理整理整理
要不要走
关我屁事
当初我在下单之前
我是怎么可能会知道
他会盘整
对吧
盘就给他盘
反正他要嘛就达到我的停损
要嘛就达到我的获利
要嘛就出去让我在中间可以不赔
就这几种结局而已
怕什么
这样懂这种感觉吗
然后来
刚刚的小娜应该开始拉回来
来来来
尖尖的
有人如果看到尖尖的吃在这种地方
你会被我打屁股
因为你尖完了就怎么样
撞墙
好不好
然后有一位网友
他问了说台股
他在9天前问的2362
这位网友他问的
我们来看一下2362
我旁边有叫在这里
然后他是在9天前问我
现在周线是不是在干净边缘
看月线是下影线K棒
日线看起来似乎要喷进去
如果打算要进场会不会太晚
好问题
你是因为看到似乎要喷上去
才想要进场
我们想要来聊一下
我们看一下九天前
今天是四月七号
所以代表在三月底的时候
你看到这个东西
今天四月七号
九天前三月底
所以你看到的时间点
大概在这个地方
你会认为说
要上去了
我应该如何规划打击区
通常这个时候
你很容易很急躁的
把老于老于下影线
这不就是老于说的尖尖的吗
你就会在尖尖的隔壁这里
然后被这个下影线吸进去
想说哇我要冲了
但是你忘记退一步看
两条线画出来
所以你问我规划打击区吗
如果他现在来到下面的两条线
来我问各位
我问各位
请问一下
上面这边的高点
有没有一直掉下来
底下的低点
有没有平平的
这个是我们讲
很多很多遍
所以如果这边出现这样子尖尖的下引线这个也不好下单了因为它的惯性怎么样惯性怎么样是在往下走的
而且这个往下走的过程中
我也看我亲眼
我的涂鸦就看得出来
各位有没有发现我用很笨很笨的方式
任何人都能做到
你只需要把这个图照着这样子
K棒把它画一画
你就这样画
你会画得出来
价格来到这边
其实如果你有涂鸦
一看就知道撞墙
所以这个尖尖的也不可能吃
所以你要做的是什么
继续涂鸦
涂鸦到这边
涂鸦到今天
来
出现这样子的图
要怎么规划打击区
很简单
如果
有出现这样子的东西
那这就会是我们有打击区的东西
对吧
那这张图什么情形下会出现这个
他就必须要再往下走一些
对不对
再往上走回来
再往下这边
你至少可以看得出围棋可能
七天到一两个礼拜打出来的这个六十
对不起
这个日线格局的边界
然后那个时候你就可以把
把我刚刚讲的那张图
这个图
你就会在这个地方看到他的
你就会比对
原来这样子
所以他还需要走这一段
那还早了
可能还要好几天或一个礼拜
慢慢等吧
那如果现在从这里就喷上去怎么办
如果你真的想吃
那就只好进到更小颗度
更小颗度
我连小时K我都看不到
好的交易点
小时K掉
你至少要出现这样子吧
把这个边界征服再来说吧
或是干脆下去小小的这个60k这样子
至少我有东西可以看
但是目前这样也都还没有
这样好不好
所以记得哦
周线是不是在干净边缘
当时的周线
一点都不干净
这个是个好案例
在上面的这几天的周线
你问我说应该是在这附近
对不对
这个人这个同学问的时候
上面一点都不干净就算有这个也一点都不干净因为他底下怎么样好多个人来碰到这个底下
所以干净边缘其实是在37点多这附近
这个才叫做干净边缘
我旁边同学聊得起来没有关系
Peter问的都还不错
Peter回答都还不错
好不好
所以我们眼前的视野
很容易被吸进去
所以我才会说我习惯退一步看
才会见术又见零
什么叫做永远看一下大格局
刚刚的这个案例就是这样子
我们在小刻度里面就很容易被这个地方
日线这里日线好强
我怕吃不到单子
你看同学的问题是
似乎要喷上去
如果打算要进场会不会太晚
你到这边才打算要进场
通常我们人性就是这样子被洗掉的
对吧
这样可以吗
好
再来
大格局怎么看
我们用
例如说
小NAT好了
来
小NAT 1K
假设我要在某个点下单
1K的这个破底翻下单
那我就一定会
我这边有一条线
我会把线
再标一次好了
好 我会把线标起来
然后开始往后退 退一下看
这条拿掉 留下那条
原来5K有一些人在用
15K呢?30K呢?
小10K呢?
原来这个地方是小10K的开高低收
也是30k的开高低收的开
开在这
所以这条边界
刚好也是小10k的边界也是这里
如果是这样子
会增加我在那个地方去下单的欲望
这样
知道这个想法吗
所以我的做法会是
我不会只看短线
我会退一步看长线
那你像我刚刚是不是带大家从短线到长线
对不对
我跟大家说平常我怎么做交易
我平常其实是这样子
来一打开
我第一个是先看大的 我先看我在大科度的哪里
来定义一下 假设眼前这根先不要出现
定义一下 来
假设这个小时9点钟的这个小时都还没开始
现在还在8点多
你看到行情这样子的 上下有点上有压下有撑
好 但是你退一步看一下小时可以你看到什么
上边界跟下边界
一秒钟就看到了
你的涂鸦会大量的落在
这些事情
这些我没有涂好
但是你的涂鸦会大量的落在这个边界上
是吧
好
所以这个时候
我定义好了60k的大边界
我就会
在60k的大边界这里
丢一条线在这里
然后呢
接下来我就进到小颗度
看一下小颗度有没有一些单子是可以让我
在这些边界区域
如果是刚刚丢的这样子进到5k进到15k
我大概就可以抓了出来
哦原来这个地方
哦你懂我意思吗
我们先做了这样子的想法
所以同样的道理
来我问大家
这个5k这里
这个老鱼老鱼破底翻在这边
这个请问这边是好的交易吗
尖尖的
有尖尖的
但是这个尖尖的是烂到不行的尖尖的
因为他发生的位阶太高了
怎么要太高来
当时的60k
你看我一丢出来
60分k的边界
我们看到干干净净
就这么刚好在这个地方
所以如果你去做
人家从底下这边
24 236这里
做到244多少
赚了200点了
然后人家都已经赚完拍拍屁股走人了
你想要赚第二波
你脑袋里想的是这样子
对吧
但是你忘记看到大壳堵的样子
你也忘记涂鸦的过程中
请问你
本来的过程是涨多跌少
涨多跌少
涨有变多吗
这里有继续涨多吗这边没有涨多还跌多光这里就是第一个市场给你的暗示什么暗示
卡布拉拉拉没力了
要爬山爬不上去了
就是这样子
本来的惯性都还在
惯性都还在突然间烂掉了
这时候就算来到这边
他的惯性也不对了
好不好
所以很多人会会这样子去吃
还有再来
同样是5K
老鱼
这个尖尖的
老鱼这里有互换尖尖的
耶
这种
你也会想吃
对吧
这个又不对
为什么不对
来再一次退一步看
大科度的边界在哪
这不是我说的
这是市场说的话
所以永远都要退
退那个一步
所以我讲一下
如果行情是这样子
看我画
行情我乱画
行情在某个盘整区间
但是结果突然间在你眼前的这个盘整
变这样
这里出现一个尖尖的
没有破底
注意
这个尖尖的
这不见得很好做
一半一半
没有到
没有到那种我会跳起来的很爱这样子
争议可以调大声1000%吗
哪里声音太小吗
同学看同学应该还好吧
对不对
这个不行
所以这一单是不行的
因为它上面斜斜的下来
底下平平的
这个很容易掉下去
那什么情况下我会跳起来
会觉得哇这单很棒
就等他这样子挣个两下
蹦戳下去
戳下去瞬间有某个力道
应该发生
却没发生
该跌没跌
同一根
我要的是同一根
咻的买上来
结果长出了一个
这样子的下影线
我不要那个
那个戳破一点点
然后你还要拿放大镜去看
去算那个点数到底差0.5
还是差0.25有破没破
那个都一样啊对事实来讲就是这个区域的边界不要去算那个一点点一个tick两个tick有破没破那个没有意义全部都同一件事
对吧
你要做的是做什么
你要做的是做明确跌破回来的这种
你可以一眼就看得出来下去回来
该下去没下去
这句话你在我们的
我们的影片这么多年的影片
你应该听了一百次有了吧
该发生没发生
是吧
所以只有这个的隔壁
才是我们讲那个赚赔比
跟获利的几率
都站在我们这边的那个点
不是到处都可以下单
但是很多人在中间就手痒
你知道吗
然后下单就说老鱼靠杯
你这尖尖的烂得要死
有很多的SOP它是有顺序的
好不好
然后有同学大家在做的很开心
来来来
这个五分K如果出现这样
现在九点半对不对
你在这边
请告诉我这个边界
上面是不是有一个厚厚的
厚厚的木板
所以出现这样
其实接下来破底的几率高
如果待会来到这边
如果待会行情来到这里
不要再吃了
我涂鸦给你看
我们刚刚同学是不是吃破底翻的
这个边界在这里
我涂鸦给你看
他回来的时候
注意看
刚好眼前是一个很真实的案例
请问你有连续性的
在你眼前出现破底翻的图吗
连续
没有啊
对吧
所以如果他又回来到这个边界
是不是斜斜的
我看EK就知道
他是不是上面很凶
长上引线
很凶的可以放这样斜斜
所以这个底下破的几率很高
老鱼没有破就上去了
上去就上去
关我什么事
我只是说几率
几率是我无法完全掌控的东西
我只能告诉你几率
那我也告诉你的是
这不符合我们常见的
的交易的那个逻辑
对吧
再来
所以
视野请你永远
如果你要做5K的单子来请养成习惯
永远往上看一下60K
那如果你要做日线的股票
请往上看一下什么看一下周线的样子好不好我用滑鼠写字这样已经算漂亮了大家不要骂我
而且我不是美术系的
我的美术天分很烂
我的字也很丑
所以我才靠大字
所以
你一定要养成一个习惯
是请往大一个刻度
这样好不好
我要补钱了
我没有放太多钱在里面
我等一下把它转一转
这个还好
它那个清算公告
是我没有放钱在我的
那个什么
股票的户头里
如果这阵子我就把钱拿出来
反正要补进去其实很快
因为我在美国那边
其实我有美金的直接的户头
要入金就很快
这样
来再来
如果眼前的惯性一直往下
高点变低
低点变低
用小朋友涂鸦
边界很烂
等它破了再回来
这就是我们刚刚讲的
好不好
有同学说
要守在区间外面
对哦
一口小纳停损都抓多少美金
10点真的太少
不是我
我没有在用固定点数停损
但是还有一个基本的门槛
例如说
例如小纳好了
小纳
我举个例子好不好
你在这个区域
不管你要吃什么
现在在EK里面
你最多的风险是要锁到这里去
没有办法
这样有20点
其实我觉得这EK不好做多
不好哦
先讲哦
我没有叫你做
拜托
我只是要说
这个地方
是
你不能只锁
例如说10点什么的
因为
你的10点
例如说不管你进场在哪一个价格
你的价格减时
我的价格减10
他的价格减10
对市场是没有意义的
市场他才不在乎
任何人的时点在哪里
你懂我意思吧
他不在乎这件事
他唯一在乎的是什么
是市场自己定义出来的边界
这个他会在乎
下去了
老鱼在说
你有沒有在听
包含这个5K
看起来很凶对不对
包含15k
啊这看起来都很凶的样子
来来来我再讲一下
现在9点35
假设到了10点钟的时候
这根K棒还是一样留着这么长的上影线
那我跟你说 接下来这个小时
想都不要想做多 完全放弃
因为你是做多在一个长上影线
很凶的K棒的隔壁
这一种很凶的K棒的隔壁往这边走的几率
非常的高 例如说这个
这个这个这里
这个长上影线隔壁
长上影线隔壁
有吧
所以千万不要
有同学说原油很凶是不是
我们看一下
原油最近都万涨啊
对
夸张又要挑战前高了
我们看一下5分K
来来来
这个5分K
老鱼这里有尖尖的
这不是一个好的做多的尖尖的地方
你懂意思吧
所以在偏上远的地方
任何做多的这些迹象
我会完全忽略
那你说老鱼
那我可不可以看到小小的空单的尖尖的就吃
也还不行
因为我看到底下一直上去
上面是平的底下斜的
你就等
等什么
等这一堆的力量干嘛
发泄掉
例如说某一个
这个上影线就我用
假设这边出现这种
把这一整段整个征服
征服然后喷出
喷出的过程中通常还会带着成交量
哇很快速的成交
结果快速的冲上去
也快速的缩回来
类似像这种的
在这个边界的隔壁
那个就好下单
因为做多的力量都冲完了
他们没力的
这样可以吗
所以那你说如果要防守要守哪里
例如说以原油
你吃在这边你还是要守这里
是整个破底番区域的
我画在这边好了
破底番
假设破底番都在这里停住
所以是这个区域的外面
但是你不能守到这里去
这样没有意义
因为如果行情都到这里来你看一下这张图长什么样这是不是又变成我们刚刚讲的斜斜的图这又不对了这里出现任何的下影线又不对了这样好不好
我们回来NQ看一下
NQ
都没有到很好
来到这边就容易出现上影线
来到这边容易出现下影线
就是我们讲的
就是边界这样子
对吧
没有到很好做
现在我很不喜欢在刚开盘的这种速度去做它
我觉得一方面是可能年纪大了
另外一方面是它跳太快了
那我的心会不由自主的跟着去很急的波动
我以前有很多大的那种亏损都出现在美股开盘的这种
啪啪啪啪啪啪啪这种速度盘里面
我死得很惨
这样
然后有同学说小SP比较漂亮
小SP我们看一下5K
哇其实现在的图我觉得
都
都有点
你知道看到这张图哦
我的第一个直觉是
我反而会希望这边
你就给我跌下来吧
跌下来1比1跌下来
打到这边出现在这里
如果有这片的单子反而比较好做
不然这里好多上影线
我今天晚上是完全不打算做任何的多单
有同学说是要做大颗度的图还是小颗度的图
看你啊
例如说你要做像刚刚的单子
你要做纯60k
就是你的最小颗度是60k
那你就往上看一下日线
然后缩到60k
不用下很大
因为60k的防守比较大
对吧
你就下个小部位
然后把小部位做长线的
你可能可以报个一两天
因为60k一出去就一两天
对不对
所以要下大颗度还是小颗度
是取决于你的当下
我决定要做60k
纯60的单
还是我决定要做5k的单
如果我决定要做5k的单子
那我就会
先看一下60k的样子
这个60k真的要往下的样子好强好强
你看一下这个上影线这样所以我会先决定我要做哪一个你必须那这个可能适合我可能适合他
可能适合他
那不见得适合你
你要去尝试一下
你的心里会有感觉
感觉说我喜欢做哪一个刻度的单子
这个我没有办法给所有的人一个标准答案
但是我可以给你一个通力是
做越短越难
一分K的杂讯越多
对心理的那些影响越大
但是反过来说
一分K是最灵敏的了
你已经可以在最边界区域
掌握到最多最多的这个东西了
就这样子
我不建议进到那么短的刻度
越大的刻度
对于我们身为散户来说
是越有利的
这样好不好
我刚刚看到同学说
要怎么
这句话我觉得很值得来讨论一下
小纳图也烂掉了
对啊ES烂掉
小纳应该也烂掉了
应该也烂掉了
对啊
来这时候
老鱼刚刚是不是有在讲
我刚刚是不是就说
这边看到这些上影线
很讨厌
有没有有没有
这个要是下来了
我几乎每一次直播
我说的东西都在直播中会发生
同学应该已经经历过不知道多少次了
对不对
来
抱不住单怎么办
第一个你必须要先去搜寻我们影片中
一个叫做亚当理论
翻亚当这几个关键字
你去搜寻一下
先把亚当理论的这个想法的观念建立起来
好
那我就用这边来当举例好不好
诶诶
该下去没下去
我们来到EK
因为现在剩十几分钟
我就准备要结束
你看它是不是跌破
注意这件事情
我刚刚在S因为
我知道这个2420年的边界
它破了
照道理讲应该要出现这种
应该要出现这样子
该发生没发生
这个边界是不是完全符合
我们现在在EK
借我拿来教学而已
完全符合边界的这个
是不是一样同一件事情
再回来看
边界这样但是他真的好下单吗来观察一下前面写写的这边这样子那我就知道了我等他市场干嘛如果市场有比较明确一点
这里
所以这边是210
200跟190
我觉得这个空间有点短
这个没有很好看
但是我看得出来这边的动态在改变
听我讲
假设我刚刚很厉害
吃在1K假设
来咯
如何报单
你需要有一个
假设我在1K做单对不对
你要有一个
大一个科度的计划
可能我看一下15K
好
我不小心吃在1K的这边
15K的高点
少说在这个地方吧
所以这边是200
这边是250
那我就知道了
我最短最短的目标
最短哦
从200做到250 260这里
这是第一目标
所以如果我在这边下两口
在这个边界上
如何抱长线呢
你需要学会出一流一
就是你不要全部的部位都
有吃到的要拉不赔
不妙
这个惯性要
我这边走的几率很高
好不好
我宁愿你不赔走掉
那我们就继续讲
假设这样子
第一目标就是做到大概这附近
第二目标
这边的一倍大约就是刚好也是这个地方
然后这边假设你的第二目标有成功来到这个地方
请你就直接蹦的出掉
所以这对1分k来说
你已经可以做一个可能长达
二三十分钟二三十跟k棒的行情
这样对一分钟线来说已经是一个不错的交易
谁叫你做1K
1K能够让你承受1分K的风险
然后报一个30分钟
够了
对吧
偶尔你会遇到很边界的1K
然后一直喷
然后喷出去5K也很漂亮
60K也很漂亮
哇 让你报了两个小时
有可能
好吗
不要乱吃哦
来
老鱼在说
你有没有在听
我刚刚
刚刚是什么地方触发了我说
这里不要乱吃的想法
就是这个
这个瞬间
他让我知道
后面还要再往下破
不要乱来
所以很多人看到这个
想说没关系
应该有就吃吃看
然后刚刚就被停损在这边
然后现在拉上来
你不觉得很闷吗
我就是要等这种东西
越来越明确的下去
还没了
5K还在杀
还在杀
这个不要
我觉得今天是一个很好的案例
为什么
今天真实的就在我们眼前发生
各种
你说各种尖尖的
但是他还没有到很好的样子
然后我们一直在挡大家
有没有
这些对我来讲是几时盘
各位应该会玩我
大概20秒到30秒吧
这样
这边这个也没有到很好下单
人人人
好不好
他下来的样子
我觉得蛮凶的
有同学说锁住抱获利睡觉
很棒啊
这是很好的想法
那我继续延伸
我们刚刚说小朋友涂鸦
那个边界要等他破了再回来
对不对
我们刚刚是不是一直在做这件事
我们在这边涂鸦
我怎么涂鸦我都看不到
看不到做多的惯性回来的样子
没有啊
对吧
所以什么情形下会回来
如果这边整理了
有一根这样子
如果有这一个
再回来以后这边这才是我的
这不就变成我们破底翻的样子吗
对吧
所以我才会跟大家说
到了边界你真的不用急
如果你是做5K的单子的人
你其实价格到了这个边界
你等个30分钟到1小时都很正常
所以通常就是价格到了
价格到这边
到了这个边界了
你就等它个一个小时以后再来看
然后通常一个小时后
你就会很清楚的看到
有一个假设这边这样子
一个小时后
这样子的单子
对吧
现在不是有空方大格局的破底翻吗
我们讲假突破对不对
你讲的现在是指这个现在吗
没有哦
那个在前面
在更早之前
我们当时不是看到有一大堆上引线
刚刚开盘的瞬间
我们不是在说
他这样上面说回来我说这个跌破这边的几率很高当时在这边我们就看到了这个边界的概念就是我们讲的长到这边冲上去冲不上去
回来的概念
就是这样子
我今天六点那边没有下单
那里我没有看到
我现在想要跟大家讲的是
我们这一切
有没有讲在前面
我是不是在判断边界
那请各位来运用我们刚刚讲的
上边界下边界
那我现在要等什么事情
如果我在盘前
这根收下影线我就要进吗
不是吧
如果我在盘前我要等什么
等它继续破
然后干嘛
同一根
某一根瞬间拉回来
所以把这一段
区间上面的上影线
透过它翻下来
会用下影线结束这一回合
这些话请你背起来
区间的上面是上影线
中间很容易翻下来
破底以后
会用下影线结束这一回合
所以我大可以在底下期待
像这样子的K棒
这是五分钟K
快收了
我可以期待下一根K棒这样子
破了这个底的隔壁
这个我就要了
或是破了底以后
隔壁这边你没吃没关系
因为再等一个小时
如果有回来
这就是我们看到的破底翻
这样可以理解吗
那你说老鱼但是他现在就上去了
好玩
他没有破对吧
那现在就上去了
好嘛我们就看一下嘛
这五分K他会收在哪
如果他收在这边
你勉强要用这个来下
好了勉强接受
因为毕竟他这个地方还很多人
底下只有两个
勉强接受
但是这个单子
哇他收的位置好尴尬
不要哦不要哦
他这一根五分K
刚刚如果收进这个里面
长这么高
那反而比较好下单
你有没有看到他刚刚这个五分K一收在下面我立刻跟大家讲说不要不要为什么不要这根五分K一收在下面 我立刻跟大家讲说不要 不要 为什么不要这根5分可以一收在下面
他是不是跟我们讲说
他很容易引发一大堆卡在这边整块
做多的人的停损
现在可能还没有 但是一不小心这些人
从7点
7点多到刚刚这一大堆做多的人
一不小心有人试驾单多按几下
破个底
我的停损会触发你的停损
你的停损触发他的停损
然后就下去了
刚刚这里其实已经触发了一次
触发这堆停损了
好不好
所以你说我这段话吗
会
其实书中一直都有这种概念
来来来来来来
带大家看一下
It's happening
It's happening right now
就是这里
你有没有看到那个跳动的速度
刚刚其实有破一瞬间
那个跳动的速度就是
这些刚刚前面的人忍不住
停顺
所以在一分K
你也不要乱摸
你再怎么样要等这样子
再怎么样
所以很多人会说
老于尖尖的吃
吃这个尖尖的
被我打屁股
吊起来打
或是刚刚的5K前面的
你在这个尖尖的隔壁就吃
吊起来打
这些都要吊起来打
好不好
不准这么做
然后现在才9点51
这个5分K还有4分钟
3分多钟才要收
你是在急什么
你一定要在这个5分K的第一秒钟就下单吗
不要吧
可以顺便准备一支笔丢一下吗
我笔已经快被我丢光光了
等我一下
我喝个水
所以今天是一个很好的案例
很好
行情回来了
下不去以后回来了
不用急
你不要急着去抢这个多单
如果你有在这边下单
我会把你吊起来打
真的不行
不要急
拜托
你就等
等他在极短格局里面
某一根真的上去了
上去了以后你看他长什么样如果他上去了以后瞬间缩回来例如说这边又变成这样或是下一根变成这样
哇 那这个破底的几率又高很多了
这样可以吗
所以买我的书附赠一支笔
让你丢的吗
那眼前我暂时留在EK
因为我想带大家一起看一下眼前的这个惯性的变化
好不好
有同学吃Snow周K尖尖的隔壁打算收入K
我们看一下同学吃的单子
Snow
诶 打错了
然后呢
周K尖尖的隔壁150
然后打算守日线区间145左右
尖尖的隔壁
可以啦
只是我看一下
周K的隔壁
你在这周吃的嘛
对不对
礼拜一礼拜二
你吃在这附近嘛
对不对
好了可以啦
算很早
我不建议你建太大的部位
如果你建十分之一十分之二的部位
我觉得还好
因为通常像这样子
你自己看
它的斜度还是在
跟我们刚刚讲的一样
所以这个你要测试它
不要拿大部位
你先测个一点点
有这样子再回来的这边
你再开始把你后面
十分之七十分之八的部位
慢慢的巴巴巴巴巴巴的加回来
这样好不好
目前26年出金扣刷卡出65万台
还是乖乖去重考
哇太厉害了
这些同学们太强了
哎哟等一下哦
这个下影线出现在这边隔壁目前好像有点上不去
哎
好这样这样子还算可以
这样还算可以
所以5k收定了
可以了对不对
1分K怎么办
宝玉这边可以做多吗
不对不对
请你养成习惯
看一下5k跟15k
这时候我可以把边界开始拉回来
这个15k还有5分钟会收
眼前其实我觉得
你不用急
因为这边很多 两种做法
一种干脆等他上去 等他回来
反而是这样子有下沙的
我反而比较知道怎么做
现在刚刚能吃的点 其实都很摸
都很摸 各位不用急
我不觉得这个行情会那么快速的这样子上去
偶尔也会遇到说
我说我不觉得这样
然后就 行情就打脸打我的脸
有啊
怎么办?不会怎么办
就错就好了
我还有要讲的
尖尖的
记得我们今天讲的
它只有发生在边界区域
而且破的才有意义
发生在区间的中间的
这里的没有破的
这里的怎么样的
这些我都不喜欢
所以你一定要先跳出去
到大颗度
先把区间画出来
这样好不好
旁边什么
月获利4万美不断出金
来给这个David
不要许下这种心愿
市场上每一个许下这种心愿的
现在都躺在地上起不来
不要许下说我每个月要赚多少钱
然后要不断出金
你这样给自己压力太大了
你要许下的心愿很简单
我只要求10次标准图出手
请你把你的焦点摆在我的出手的标准图上
10次就好
对吧
10次耶
那你就好
我要连续3次的10次
3个轮
这样可以
你不要聚焦在前这边
旁边的所有的学长们应该都可以作证
你许下一个这种
我要一直赚钱的心愿的时候
你就躺在地上了
你就会变成一直刷卡
一直爆掉一直刷卡
买账号的这种刷卡仔
爆账仔这样
不要啦
好不好
然后最后拉回来
我们的做法会不会错
当然会错啊
市场是几率的
但是因为从我们的交易
刚刚来咯
不要哦
这个一分k这样太凶了
这边肯定
正在走 对不起
对 你看你看对吧这就是我讲不要乱吃这里反而很关键
这里好
很好
我从这些地方看
小时k在两分钟要收了
各位想要做多的同学
请你把手绑起来
或是把账号给锁住
锁到今天晚上
直接完全不要看
这一根这么凶的小时k
拜托各位
下一根不要碰了
碰都不要碰
同学说身为一个上过小群主客
自己心态稳住
还有慢就是快
真的就是这样
所以不要想说要赚很多钱
各位这个小10k很讨厌
剩两分钟到一分钟要收了
我不信他能够收回到哪里去
剩一两分钟
这个1分K这样子会让人家想下单
我知道
5K也不行
15K也更不行
15K很凶
这边15K就是要收定的
这一收定就是往这边翻
你看一下我翻下去的
对吧
所以不要不要不要
OK
没有改变做单方式突然间大转
很好啊
我觉得同学很厉害
真的
很不好很不好
来
那我要来聊
我正面来聊一下赚赔币
我们的做法是这样子
我们做在下面的边界的尖尖的
那我们说过
这个尖尖的是小格局的破底翻
它就会融合成一个
大一个刻度的尖尖的
对吧
如果我在五分K看到尖尖的
那就代表在一分K
一定是长这样子
长这样子
出现在这个里面
那尖尖的隔壁
我的停损了不起
如果这个尖尖的够短
了不起是这样子
那如果这个尖尖的下影线很远
那我就会守这个边界
顶多就是这样子
然后这个地方
我会在更短刻度里面去持
所以我看得到短格局
我的利润呢
我通常都是在区间的下缘我就会习惯做到区间的上缘所以光这边1我将目测的比率1比4 1比5的赚赔比是很有用的
所以我获利一次
我会有多出来的超额的利润
让我拿来赔
赔普通的这种试单
我会错
但我不在乎错
我不会一直拿
我这个错要怎么样变对
还是我被停损了要不要改做空
还是我被停损要不要改做多
我没有这个想法
我就只有一个想法就是
我要做的就是错错对
那只要我对的时候
我把教育计划给做出去
刚刚同学讲的报单
我做出去后
其实长期下来
一加一减长期下来
你会赚得到钱
但是大家都太急
所以以至于在很多不是尖尖的地方
或是不好的尖尖的
就拼命的下单
同学说的对啊
到头来对手就是自己而已
只做单边
2022有做空吗
没有 我没有做空
2022已经是进入我
22之前我早就都在做多而已
所以我的习惯
我已经很久很久不做空单了
这样
那空单有没有赚的快
有
空单摔下来的速度真的很快
但是我就不做
我以前有试着想要多空都掌握过
但是那段多空都掌握的日子
反而是我人生中赔最多
最痛苦的那段日子
因为
我的脑袋每天都在烧
你知道吗
就是都在那个CPU100%的程度
这里做多
这里可以做空吗
做多做空做过做
每一秒钟我都在烧
不行啊
我的脑袋其实很烂
我相信各位跟我一样
我们的脑袋的脑容量很有限
所以稍微一点多一点决策在脑袋里面
我们就热当机了
对不对
对啊
所以我不觉得
我不觉得我会
重新的多空多做
没有
所以我宁愿的就是
就是多单我就做我的
空单呢?
空单就留给别人做
就这样子
好不好
来
老于在说我这时候又要再拿亚当出来讲了老于在说你有沒有在听我刚刚是不是说这个1k
那边我说但是我很不喜欢
有没有有没有
这边有亚当小满足
有1比1这边差不多
那等吧
好不好
你说我有考别的平台
有我最近在试那个
Tradify
因为前两天我又收到一个
一个TS这边的讯息说
我的交易有
他们系统有好像有微微的当机
然后我有受影响到
还好是没有真的造成负的亏损
他说如果有可以联络他
这样
所以我最近我在试那个Tradify
这样子
所以我今天早上我才刚录了一支影片
好不好
就是录我使用Tradify的
这些心得什么的这样
对啊
最近买了PS5玩什么游戏吗
有啊 我买了什么
霍格华兹 那给小朋友玩的
我也跟着玩 还不错
还有The Show 2006 有没有 棒球游戏
身为棒球人一定要玩的 对不对
然后里面的大鼓真的很强
然后还有什么啊
我还买了什么
我想看这个还有一个小朋友 蜘蛛人啊
蜘蛛人
蜘蛛人小朋友很爱玩
说60k有没有可能把整段翻下去
有啊我觉得60k很有可能
我还希望它翻下来一点
各位拜托
我们刚刚是不是在这一秒钟
我们就看到说
不行这60k
我说这个看来还要翻下去
我还记得那时候我们是切ES
那我就说
我还希望它翻下来
有没有
老于在说你要听
本金2000美金做黄金一周能赚1000
看了我的课程之后
没有啦
不是我的课程厉害啦
是你自己厉害啦
不过说真的哦
我建议你
通常这样子就是
本金2000一周能赚1000
我会建议你稍微缓一下
因为这个时候是我们最容易
在这个时候膨胀的时候
所以如果可以
你把你下单的部位降一半
好不好
然后获利可能也少一半没关系
我想要刻意的帮你再
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:20:00 起〕